okay i think it started
perfect
um all right so um first of all good
evening uh good morning good afternoon
from wherever you're joining us um from
um
we we did like couple of um paper
readings before but um then we stopped
and now we're sort of reviving the whole
paper readings and we're starting off
with data to work um in case you're um
you you're looking for
the uh the url to the paper itself it's
linked in the slides um which are shared
in the ml for audio
um
paper
um just a couple of quick points um this
is supposed to be a paper reading so um
i i really don't want this to be like a
one-way session of sort uh this is not a
session at all this is a discussion um
so
i've put together some rough slides and
the intention is that
as and when we go through these slides
um at the end of each tag we we sort of
like discuss what exactly happened in
the paper and you know talk about um
what what happened post data to work um
you know what happened pre data to work
and you know compare um results um data
to work is a multi-modal uh model
however i will be focusing um quite a
lot on the speech aspects of it um there
would be some
um there would definitely be some um
aspects of text as well as cv which
which i'll cover which i thought were
really interesting but by and large this
would be focused on
um speech
um so before we get started are there
any questions or any initial thoughts
comments that anyone would like to share
okay
um
no worries but um at
any point from now on you can just you
know um
unmute yourself and just like share your
thoughts if you want to um so um let's
get started um so
when i read the paper data to work uh
initially my my whole like thought
process was that hey this is like like a
completely novel architecture of its um
of its own however data to work is um is
a framework right so um it is
essentially a way through which um you
can use the same learning method um for
all the three modalities so for speech
natural language processing and computer
vision right um and uh data to wake um
essentially builds on
how wave tweak 2.0 um worked um if you
remember um that um just a quick recap
the way wave to a 2.0 worked was by
trying to predict the latent
representation of the input data um uh
you know um
you know of the input data so so
essentially the model learns from itself
right and uh data to work basically
takes the same
same um
process and removes some complexity of
quantization from it um we'll get to
that later um but essentially simplifies
the the learning object a bit more and
then applies it across all the three
modalities right so um it does the same
thing for speech it does the same thing
for nlp um does the same thing for
computer vision right so um this
this was the first framework um
um at its time to um
to be able to come up with a with a way
to use the same learning method
before data to wake um there were like
state-of-the-art learning methods or
like objective functions um as you may
call it um for like
for individual um
modalities for example for speech there
is uh huber type learning wherein like
you um you learn from iterations of
model or we have to wait 2.0 types um uh
type learning wherein you do
quantization and like you know uh have
like specific code books from where you
learn um uh
uh selections from similarly for like
natural language processing there is of
course mass language modeling um and
then like different variations of it um
and you know similarly for computer
vision as well right um but
but this here is an attempt to um
essentially unify uh the objective
function and um
and you know um then sort of make the
model learn um on different modalities
right
and
we'll get to the architecture in in just
about one or two slides um but the core
idea here again is to just predict the
latent representations of the full input
data um
you know based on a masked view of the
input right so um it uses a teacher
student
architecture wherein you know
the teacher at any given point of time
will have the full view of
what the input is and the student gets a
masked view of that input and is um is
supposed to predict um what exactly is
the
um the mast view of the input right um
if if this did not make sense uh right
now it will make more sense as we go
through a couple more slides right um
now let's dig a bit more deeper right so
what exactly um is happening over here
right so
if we if you look at
um the the three different modalities
right um they have like very different
um sub units so for example for
um
for text um a sub unit would would
either be a word or a sub word um for um
for an image it would either be like a
patch on the image or you know some sort
of a visual token for for human speech
it could be just like a 20 millisecond
snippet of it which may or may not have
like one entire um unit and so on so all
of these are like really really um
really really different from each other
more than that
all of these individual modality
specific targets as they as the paper
calls it um are really really dependent
on the context that surrounds it right a
very simple example of this from a
speech standpoint would be that uh when
we speak um the pronunciation or like
the way we uh we speak differs
based on what surrounds um the word
right for example honest um in in in the
word on it sorry honest we don't really
um pronounce the word h that's because
like o is in the vicinity of the um
letter h right um and there are like
multiple examples like that so um what
is important is that we
um we figure out a way to like
one
learn this context right um and while we
learn this context also become like
really good at like understanding what
exactly are we predicting right and uh
that's what data to wake uh attempts at
doing so it um it attempts at predicting
the context for latent representations
right and we'll get to how how it gets
to the uh gets to the contextual part
but a lot of um recent architectures
they they they have been doing
self-supervised learning right so what
they would typically do right um right
now would be to just take
one layer or like the the last layer of
the network and try to mask that and try
to predict that right um that may or may
not be the best layer um and so on um
and
what
data to vectors is it essentially uh
takes an average representation across
layers and they did some habitation
study on that which we'll also cover in
a bit um
to then like um get like an average
contextual latent representation that
the model learns to
predict um
so i'm gonna take a quick pause here and
see if we have any questions
okay no questions are good questions as
well
um
okay so let's um let's let's um
go a little bit more deeper into this
right what exactly is um happening here
right so um as we figured out so far um
that data to vex unifies the learning
algorithm um uh you know fall across
the three modalities uh however um the
way it it works presently it still
learns like the representations
individually right so it uses the same
learning function right um however it's
not as if that you're you're feeding
image text and um speech all to it at
the same time and it's learning
from all three of those at the same time
rather it uses the same objective
function but learns individually right
so this is like a this is like a step in
the direction of
learning everything all in one go
however
the work still
requires you to have three individual
models right so there would be one model
which employs the same learning function
but for speech there would be one model
which employs the same learning function
but for
cb and for text and so on right
but the key part is the learning
algorithm
over here
right now we've been talking about this
this learning algorithm for quite a
while what exactly is this learning
algorithm right
um
this learning algorithm is basically the
method which combines mask prediction so
this is something which all of us know
um or like have been sort of reading
about from uh pre-birth era um
as well and more from like bird era um
which is to you know
um
make the model sort of learn um
to to predict the gaps in in a target
representation right so uh this method
essentially um
feeds in a target representation uh a
masked target representation to the um
to the student model and or or well to
the model while it learns and then the
model learns to predict what exactly
should be there um in place of um the
mask right um
the model or the architecture here being
a transformer architecture right
and how does it how does it do that so
it does it does it in like two steps
right the first step is that um you
build representation of the full input
data so um like
whatever your input sample is you build
the representation for the entire data
um and um
you know this is done using a teacher uh
model so we'll get to the difference
between of between the teacher model and
student model in a bit but right now
just assume that a teacher model is a
back is a black box and the teacher
model essentially takes in the input
data and gives you some sort of an
embedding um
or you know a representation of the
input data out right
and then there is a student model let's
also assume that this is a black box for
now um this takes the masked version of
the representation that the teacher
model gives and uh then tries to predict
the full data right um so one thing to
note over here that you would have
realized that unlike mass language
modeling and and so on wherein the model
tries to
just predict the mask um over here the
student uh model essentially predicts
the entire data representation right so
um
it also learns uh
the dependencies um that are uh
you know um before and after the mask as
well right so the model is forced to
predict the entire data representation
instead of just filling the blanks right
and and um this to me was a really
interesting point um in the uh in the
entire paper
um before we get to the get to the
teacher and the student mode
i'm going to take a quick pause to see
if there are any questions here or any
thoughts or comments
about this
perfect um
let's let's look at the architecture in
a bit more detail right so um we spoke
about two things so far one is the
learning algorithm which is same across
modalities and the second is um that it
it has a
student teacher uh training model right
teacher gives the
entire representation of the input data
um whereas student gets a masked version
of that and tries to predict the full
data representation from it right
now what exactly is um is the teacher
and the student here the teacher and the
student have the same architecture
except
the weights of the teacher model
are
are essentially initialized with an
exponentially decaying average of the
student model so think of it as
the student model is always one step
ahead
of um the teacher model right so um
during every you know iteration of
learning um
the the teacher model weights are
initialized to the previous student
model you can like that's a great way to
sort of put the um put the analogy right
so that's how the self um supervised
learning sort of happens right so the
teacher model is essentially um um
an exponentially decaying averaged
like like has the has the same
architecture
everything is the same um except it is
like um
just think of it as like one um epoch
behind the student model and then like
the student model tries to sort of
you know knowing what it knows tries to
like learn more from it right and this
keeps on like um interchanging and and
so on and so forth
um i hope that gives you
a good picture of it right um in case
that was not clear um
let's look at this um this diagram from
the paper um so what it does is that we
have let's take for example um speech
over here so we have um the original
this is the entire waveform right and um
there would be some representation of
this waveform um
which we will get from a feature encoder
um in a bit we'll get to what the future
encoders are but assuming that they are
a black box um we get a representation
of this waveform and then we um you know
mask this representation right this this
representation then then is like fed to
um
uh fed to the student model right which
then tries to um
you know predict the
the entire representation of the
original input in itself right and uh
because the because the teacher model is
is essentially a weight decaying average
um
off the
student model
um
the teacher tracks the weights right so
now you can you can sort of um
understand it more from like um
epoch to epoch or like you know um one
entire pass of data to the other entire
pass of data you can you can see that um
um
the student model
in like one
generation if i may call it uh becomes
the teacher model for the next
generation right for the next pass of
data and and so on so um
your your your teacher also becomes like
um stronger as the passes of the data go
through
and and you know your your student of
course is like one step ahead of that so
um
it gets better because it it gets better
at predicting the um overall
representation of the
original input
um
right and um
one thing to note over here is that um
since the different modalities so
modalities being the images speech and
the language um have like really really
different inputs um
you know in one case it's pixel in the
other case it's it's actually a waveform
and the other one there are like uh you
know words
um
the the data to wake framework employs
um you know modality specific feature
encoders and um there are also like
different masking strategies that they
involve but but by and large um they are
um sort of like relatable um in itself
but the key thing to note here is that
the way we create these representations
that the student model is supposed to
learn
is different is different for each of
the modality
um so i know i've been talking quite a
lot of gibberish um so i'm going to take
a quick pause to see if if we have any
discussion point here or something to
talk about here
okay um
let's get going
um
i think um
one thing uh in this slide which which
uh truly did not really make um sense to
me that much and especially like when i
was um just like reading it for the
first time um was that um in this kind
of a setup like wherein the the teacher
model is essentially learning from the
student model
you know um as well there is a really
high chance of collapse right while
while learning so there could be a
scenario wherein like a bias creeps in
um into the prediction of um of student
model and um you know that bias could
just like quite very well easily be
um
be like flow in throughout the
training iteration so um i wasn't quite
sure um
you know
what's the best way one to avoid it or
um you know it is or if it is a
um
it is a problem in the first place um
but yeah i i still don't have an answer
to it if in case anyone has an answer or
has any thoughts on that then feel free
to um unmute yourself and
um
you know we can discuss
but cool um we can
let's get let's get going and you know
uh feel free to pause me um at any point
so
um
[Music]
i like up until now um
we've we've looked at the overall
architecture of um
data to work we've seen that it can
handle different modalities however we
did learn that it use it uses modality
specific feature encoders uh and you
know the masking strategy is different
um
as well and we also learned that it it
works in a student teacher mode um
and and learns to predict the overall
representation but what does this
actually mean um with respect to speech
right um so if you compare data to work
with um um
with wave to wait 2.0 um data to wake um
predicts the contextual latent
representations directly right so in
wave 2.0 in case um if you remember
there was a quantization step right the
quantization step was um was for the
model to explicitly learn the hidden
units of of speech right and um
quick refresher the reason why we need
to learn these units of speech is so
that uh you know
because speech is not like text right so
you you you cannot really really like
split speech into um 10 millisecond
uh sections or 20 milliseconds section
um sections and say that this
this 20 millisecond section corresponds
to a
or this um section corresponds to you
know c or d or and and and so on um
so
that's why we need to learn how exactly
uh do these like we have to learn these
speech uh spoken language units right
and what data what data2x does is it
removes the the quantization section and
it directly just learns to predict the
contextual license representations so
um it
in a sense it removes the complexity
that quantization um uh had in wave 2.0
which also resulted in in it being um a
sort of unstable model when it comes to
pre-training um as well so the data to
work
in it in itself sort of like simplified
wave to weight 2.0 right and um the the
other sort of um state-of-the-art model
uh which is hubbard um uh the way it is
different from uh from from from
hubert to to data to wake is um hubert
essentially uses different layers across
like iterations so it does two
iterations uh and and it uses like um
it uses the representations from those
um layers to predict
um
these representations whereas data to
wake up predicts um the average over
multiple layers right so
um
like a quick quick sort of um
quick point here
there have been multiple researches uh
specifically in speech which say that um
for example for models like wave to way
2.0 or for hubert um the last layer of
the model
isn't really the best representation of
the input data to it like doesn't really
give you the best uh representation
right that's why in in in the case of
hubert they they zero down on the eighth
layer of the network um and you know um
for for for like the small model and i
think the 12th for the large model maybe
getting the exact layer wrong um and
what not but um what data2x does is it
it averages the results over you know
multiple layers and they did some
abolition studies on like how many
layers are the best number of layers and
so on um but that sort of um helps
remove the bias of just using the best
um layer that they found during their
experiments right so in this case um
they actually did some meaningful
analysis to um to see
what k sort of works best k meaning how
many number of players do we um do we
switch from so by now you would have
realized that there are if we if you
were to draw like direct parallels from
wave to web 2.0 um uh data to work is
pretty much the same
as we we have to wait 2.0 except with a
different
um
learning strategy right like except
except with a different learning
function uh wave 2.0 had a very
different learning function and in this
one would just would just like
predicting
the full contextual date and
representation right without any need
for quantization or any uh need for um
you know a synthetic um uh generation of
um
spoken language units as well
um
right so before we get to
um the architecture um
we'll take another pause and see if we
have any thoughts questions or comments
and in case you um don't want to unmute
yourself you can also just
ping on the discord chat as well
okay
um let's talk architecture now so um
the the architecture is is basically the
standard transformer architecture um you
know um however the interesting thing
over here um is that each and every
modality has a um has a separate feature
encoder right and the reason for that is
it's quite simple because each modality
has a has a really different
um
input right so for example in in case of
computer vision we have um you know
images in case of speech we have
waveforms whereas in case of text it's
just like one dimensional um you know
text so
um whilst the learning method was
is the same across all all modalities
the way we generate representations are
different still right um so for for for
computer vision they use um v um with
specific strategy so they they encode um
the image as a sequence of patches um
and you know each um spans across 16 16
and um you know
it's it's it's it's input to a linear
transformation i am not um familiar with
wit or computer vision that much so
um i i just took this directly from the
um from the paper um for speech um
it pretty much copies how vp 2.0 um
works so it takes um it works on the
waveform so it does not require any uh
male spectrogram representation or
something like that as hubert requires
so
it directly models the waveform and it
has the exact same um you know uh
multi-layer um convolution network um to
um
to take like 25 millisecond waveform
snippets and you know down sample it
um in case of text um they
they use um sub word units and um they
if i'm not mistaken they use a roberta
um architecture to
you know
feature in code um
the
to get the input up sorry to get the
representation of the input data um so
again so
there's nothing novel in the
architecture itself but the novelty is
in the in the learning uh
function or the objective function
over here
and
across
across the across modalities when it
comes to masking um you know again like
the the input sample it goes through um
it goes through um
it is sorry um i got lost for a second
um the the the the input sample is
embedded and um as a sequence token of
course right and we get like some sort
of a representation out of the feature
encoder out um you know from it and this
representation um then is masked so
roughly they they aim to mask around
like 0.65 um
like 65 of the of the data and like then
have the model sort of learn
the
learn to predict the overall
overall
representation um
and and yeah so
once the mast embedding token is
is in place within the sequence then it
is it is fed back into the student model
for it to predict the um the overall
um
sequence right um so
again nothing nothing novel over here um
the way they mask um sort of differs
from like speech to text to
um
um to image um however um
uh
the fact that
it is 65 percent masked um still remains
the same
i can hear myself for some reason does
anyone have anything to
say discuss or questions
um anyway i'm just gonna ignore that uh
for now um so then
um then now that's that's like masking
so so that's what uh well that's what
the the model is sort of learning
and
then comes uh the training targets so
now
as we learned the training targets are
essentially um
the the representations however like
mass representation so you're
essentially learning the entire um
entire
learning to predict the entire uh
representation in itself right
um
and like one important point over here
is that uh
the representations that we that we
predict um in this entire um
in this entire sort of setup um these
are contextual representations right um
so um any particular like
like when we when we um give the input
to the student model
it is for a particular time step however
like the transformer architecture has
like self-retention sort of embedded in
it so uh each and every one of those
sample would would have information like
each and every one of those time steps
samples would have information of the
entire sort of uh
input right so um um in that sense the
model is just not like learning to fill
the blanks um however like the model
learns to sort of generate uh quote
unquote um the entire representation
given like whatever little information
it has from the masked uh representation
right so um that's that's kind of the
important bit um over here as well
um
then we get to the objective function
the objective function um is um a sort
of a smooth l1 loss and and it
progresses across um
all the targets so
the
the targets here are like different time
steps so you essentially want to get the
value for that time step right um and so
on and they they introduce um a better
value over here which is which is this
one um and the reason why we have this
um
can i have oh okay
now i have a cool fancy laser pointer uh
this
this better value is here to
essentially make make the model less
less likely to collapse in the event of
outliers right um
and uh
you you you would have probably guessed
this right that this this beta is also a
tunable parameter over here and it would
differ a bit from um say for example a
speech
[Music]
you know training
setup to say an image
and so on and the reason why this is
important is
we want the model to
not explicitly not learned how to
interpolate right um what is in in a
self-supervised setup um what is quite
easy for the the architecture to learn
is
given the previous time step it just
like interpolates the next thing so the
model essentially uh learns like a next
step prediction um
of of model to learn that we want the
model to like um
to like learn
everything
um that there is within the sample and
like learn to predict the entire sample
from just like one time steps and and
and so on right um and and that's why um
having a better value um over here to
sort of um
you know control the transition um helps
quite a lot
um
right so
before we get into a bit more details
about speech and then like look at the
results
[Music]
i'm going to take a quick pause to see
if we have any
thoughts or comments
[Music]
here
oh yeah
perfect um um
yeah i mean if if if anyone has any
thoughts um then feel free to share them
um or just you know um unmute yourself
and
um just talk at at any point of time uh
in terms of um the presentation or in
terms of the slides we're almost
near the end so we can also discuss some
cool stuff which i found in the paper uh
and and you know you can you can always
just unmute yourself and say hey this
does not make sense and you know
why did they not do say x instead
instead why do they choose y as well so
um
any sort of questions are good questions
um
in case i wasn't clear
cool so
now that we've spoken or now that we've
looked at the overall architecture right
um so far um
let's look at specifically from like a
speech standpoint um what exactly is
happening here right
um
so um
long story short uh everything is
exactly the same as wave to web 2.0
except the learning
function but to break it down into the
three parts um the feature encoder
is the same as wave to way 2.0 like even
in the hugging phase implementation of
data to wick um they use this like same
uh wave 2.0
um
feature encoder the
the masking strategy is uh is the same
um as well so even though they they aim
for 0.65 but you know when you um
include when you take into account the
silences and stuff like that it it comes
down to like 49
um of all time steps um were masked uh
for the training sequence the fine
tuning strategy is also the same as wave
to big 2.0 this is same across all
modalities right um so um the bit that i
really liked about data to wake is it
reduces the complexity of
um quantization so essentially makes
learning well quite easy and also like
makes the whole like pre-training less
likely to collapse um when when compared
to paperback 2.0 um
but while while doing that while
reducing the complexity it also beats
wave to a 2.0 right so
um
it's it's basically a win-win with um
with very less sort of
changes to the um overall training
mechanism right
um and
let's look at the results um so i've
only put the results for um
speed stuff um
because i thought like that was more
relevant
over here but you can already see
that um
we have to like for
so what this table is showing you right
now is um
base models and large models for like
paperback 2.0 hubert wavelm and you know
compare them with data to wick right um
and what kind of language model was used
as well and what you see uh on what you
see from here all the way till till the
end of the table are word error rates so
um word error rates are general like the
lower the word error rate the more
precise and and the more accurate your
model is right um
and this is the amount of label data
that was supplied to the model um
to to you know train so all of these
models were uh pre-trained on the entire
960 hours libra speech data set and um
then they were fine tuned um only on 10
minutes then one hour then 10 hours then
100 hours then you know then again like
960 hours of data to uh to then get
uh
their final word error rate right um and
you can like there are like a couple of
things which which become like really
really clear right off the bat right so
um one one area where data to work
excels is you know at um um less um like
when you have less amount of data um so
if you if you compare 12 point like the
word error rate of 12.3 uh with we have
to wait 2.0 is um 15.6 over here um or
cubits 15.3 um that's a that's a massive
improvement in my opinion right and that
too given the fact that it has um a
significantly less complex
um
um you know uh
learning mechanism as compared to say we
have to wait 2.0 or hubert as a matter
of fact right
when we go to the large model for the
same amount of less speed you know less
less data you can see that um there is
also like some uh some improvement here
so it's it's it's eight point four over
here and it was ten point three four
five two point oh and you know ten point
one for hubert um and and mind it like
all of these models were pretend on the
same
amount of unlabeled data use the same
language model um so
they are being compared one to one um
over here
um and also because wave to web 2.0 and
um you know hubert as well as well as
data to wake by and large have the same
architecture as well uh in terms of like
the future encoder the
um um
uh
yeah i mean like in in in in terms of
the layers so
it's not that one model has like
significantly large number of parameters
um and and the other one does not um so
it's
quite one-to-one comparison um
comparison when it comes to that um you
can also see for like one hour um
there is like at least a two point word
error rate um
uh gain right um same for 10 r as well
same four hundred dollars as well for
960 yards as well um
and so on um
i honestly don't really see the point of
like putting 960 hours um over here
because well you've already like
pre-trained on 960 hours of unlabeled
data anyway right so you you're
essentially just like reinforcing
whatever it is um
um your model learned during the
pre-training phase right so um i don't
think so this is that that valuable
however um
uh my key takeaway from from the entire
thing was that data to wic um
models using data to wick framework uh
trained using the data to work framework
um are significantly
um better at
you know low amount of um data so if you
have like very less amount of data and
just want to quickly
test you know how the performance would
be on like downstream um asr tasks um or
you know speaker verification tasks or
you know something like that then um
this might be
the way to go
um at least for now
um
gonna take a quick pause
to see if we have any thoughts comments
questions here
nice um let's head over to um
well the conclusion and and also some
part of the uh future work right um so
like of course um
i think the
um the the authors did a fantastic job
to um sort of talk about the self
talk about how self supervised learning
um can be used
you know like the framework can be used
across like vision speech and language
um and you know um of course um their
idea of not just like
predicting um what the mask is but also
like predicting the entire um latent
representation given um a partial view
is also quite novel
um
and you know
this is um something which um which can
be just applied to like some um
some other like modality specific
architectures and you know could could
give like um really nice results uh
straight off the bat um and a couple of
things which i which i found really
interesting in the future work was um
that they said that they would they
would want to see like how uh this kind
of a setup would work for say for
example audio visual speech recognition
right wherein you can you have like same
sort of uh masking
masking across both the
uh the image input as well as the audio
input and you know have some sort of a
similar feature encoder for both of them
to see like how
um how this kind of a learning mechanism
performs over there um they also spoke
uh spoke a bit about um
you know um about investigating um
single masking strategy so like medal
modality agnostic um masking strategy
um
um
as in this case they had slightly
different um
uh methodology so um you know just
having like similar masking um strategy
might might be like the first
step towards having like a universal
feature encoder for like all different
types of modalities um in this
particular setup
um
so
that was the
that was a that was a quick download on
what data2x does
before i sort of like um
um open the floor for for discussion and
like i i do want to sort of discuss the
abolition studies um and and and the
results of that um if you if you want to
test out the data to work model on
hugging face um there are about 42
different models right now um and um you
know there are some models which are
specifically fine tuned for text um and
you know for for like specific
corporates with index as well so um do
make sure to to check them out if you
want to just directly test um test the
asr model um you can just go to the link
um that i've put in the
um in the slides and um uh just test
them out and um uh it should work right
off the bat
as well
um so with that i am gonna
take a pause and see if we have any
questions thoughts comments um
discussion points
over here
nice um
so then uh maybe we we like quickly
check the the abolition studies because
that that to me was probably the best
part of the paper i did not have the
time to put this in the slides but maybe
before i share the sites on the um i
like upload the sites on on github i uh
add that as well for like um future
viewing um but what they did was they
um they essentially
so let me first
um
zoom in a bit i hope it's it's it's
visible i'm sorry if it isn't i am on a
low resolution monitor right now um
but um they did like
two or three different types of they ran
two or three different types of layer um
sorry uh ablation studies so one was on
like how many number of layers should
they use um
you know when when when they're like
predicting the contextual uh latent
representations or like how many layers
um
you know what
what do you predict like how many number
of layers do you like average um
essentially and um if you see here k is
the number of layers so you can see that
um when you just use the last layer
um or when you just use like one layer
or or two layer the water rate is
incredibly high so it's like all the way
up to like 40 or like in this case i
know something around 48 um or something
like that but it like significantly goes
down as
as you go from like the fourth to fifth
one right and then like further from
like fifth to sixth and um yeah if you
use all then it's like of course like it
sort of like
bottoms around eight if i'm not wrong
and then uh pretty much follows the same
um same um you know aspect um so for
speech it does have like a have like a
considerable um
you know
uh considerable change when you when you
take like more layers into consideration
um whereas for like natural language
processing um or like for like for like
text based um tasks you can see that the
the glue score sort of
improves or like increases um quite
quite sort of um quite a lot from like
the first to the second layer and then
like um a bit more from third and then
after that
there's like minimum sort of
increase
um
for vision um it increases or like peaks
at
three number of layers um and then like
sort of decreases and
produced towards the end i'm not sure
why this happens um
my my non-speech background sorry my
non-image background
inhib like prohibited me to understand
what the reason behind this is but if if
any one of you know image
um
or like have worked with image-related
tasks and and have like a
um thought
or or like some idea as to why this is
happening then feel free to unmute
yourself and talk about it
right and
um also the
the next thing that they tried was
um was like
how much like like how much
contextualization should happen in the
target right
um
so
like
how much of the target should the
should the model or like the student
model try to predict right
um
and as you can see like the word error
rate of course like improves
considerably when you try to predict
everything right um but then again you
can also see that you can you can get
you know significantly faster uh
training runs because like from sixteen
point two percent to like hundred
percent
um there is very little
um gain or well
gain in terms of word error rate right
um
so
at least for speech um
you you might just be better off with
just you know predicting 20 of the
context um and and you know so on um and
so forth
um
and and you know that that in itself was
um quite interesting um there was also
something about like target feature
types um but that's that's just the same
as you know predicting what you present
uh what you're predicting um in itself
um so that that that wasn't that
interesting but in my opinion the uh the
most interesting bit was um you know the
context size as well as like how many
number of players do you average um your
target um in and um it also solves like
a really important um problem
specifically from like speech standpoint
if you look at the um historical
literature um of wave to wave 2.0 or
hubert wherein like you're you're pretty
much at the beck and call of the layer
that you select
um to you know learn from so
um this sort of overcomes that challenge
and also significantly um
creates a significantly easier
um
learning mechanism
um
before we call it a day um
one thing that i would recommend
everyone to
read is
you know this particular paragraph from
the paper which is representation
collapse
this is something which i at least from
like speech background haven't seen a
lot of
papers talk about but um
a lot of large models have this tendency
to collapse when they're you know either
pre-training uh typically when they're
pre-training uh collapse means that the
the model just stops learning or or like
learns something um as trivial as you
know just next um time step prediction
or you know something like that um so
uh
or or or you know uh it just learns to
uh or just like stops to learn or and
just like predict like
uh
just like randomized representations and
so on right um and um they basically did
like
um a really nice analysis on like what
caused um representation collapse in um
in in in all of their runs
and um like the first was that um in
case the learning rate was too large or
the learning rate warm-up was too short
then um
then you know then um
the student model would
effectively collapse um then they then
they found that um
specifically for like um highly
correlated
um targets like for example speech
wherein like everything is dependent on
the previous um you know time step uh in
those kind of scenarios um yeah you know
uh it is quite likely that the model
just learns to predict the next time
step and uh does not really care about
um the overall context so in case of
speech um over there they they address
this by um
normalizing the target representations
uh again the same way as um wave to
weight 2.0 does
um so i found that like really
interesting i've never
like i've seldom come across a
representation collapse section within a
paper so i found this to be like um
quite interesting
um but yeah with that um
um thank you so much for uh
tuning in and i'm still around if you
have any questions
but yeah that's that's pretty much it
from my
presentation
and if you don't have questions then you
can of course
leave
you